le conseil départemental de la réunion
vous présente lien social le conseil
départemental aux côtés des réunionnais
la forêt est au coeur de la réunion et
des réunionnais le département est donc
fier en tant que propriétaire de 100 %
des forêts à la réunion de proposer à
bélouve un parcours de 220 mètres de
long en immersion totale
accessible à tous ainsi qu'une
exposition permanente sur le tamarin des
hauts le massif de bélouve est l'un des
massifs les plus fréquentées de l'île
c'est un espace préservé d'une très
grande naturalité au coeur du parc
national est inscrit au patrimoine
mondial
qu'est ce qui a été mis en place pour
l'accessibilité pour tous à bélouve on
en parle tout de suite d'un lien social
la forêt de bélouve a été retenu comme
site pilote pour développer un pôle
nature accessible à tout public dans le
cadre d'une démarche innovante et
partager avec les représentants des
utilisateurs
le sentier de découverte somain tamarins
est une immersion tout confort dans la
forêt humide des eaux de l'est
l'ensemble des panneaux et transcrit
dans des audio guides disponibles au
gîte et les mal voyants sont guidés par
des fils d'ariane et par des bandes
podotactiles au sol tout au long de ce
projet des personnes en situation de
handicap pour conseiller orienter et
valider les équipements au cours du
comité de pilotage et de test du site
jean-bernard ce hangar ya en a fait
partie le fut nullement en bois et tout
était bien
fait pas ce qu'il faut savoir qu'à la
base ça a été travaillé avec plusieurs
associations
on n'est pas la seule association
heureusement sur le projet de la mise en
place de salles y avait des associations
de personnes handicapées et des non
voyants des malentendants qui permettait
d'avoir un complément pour l'ensemble
des personnes et ça fait que ben ça a
rendu ce ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui qui
est quand même très bien le fait de ce
parcours ça permet à toutes les
personnes en situation de handicap de
pouvoir pénétrer un peu à l'intérieur de
la forêt et de bach toucher sentir être
plus près de la nature
quand vous êtes au milieu tavaux santé
et puis vous entendez aussi une certaine
de plénitude un moment où vous êtes
ballan dans le coeur vous entendez les
oiseaux
voilà au gîte du vélo c'est qu'on peut
aussi on peut prévenir à l'avance en
arrivant nous ouvrent la barrière en bas
qui nous permet de monter jusqu'à oki un
parking prévu pour les personnes à
mobilité réduites et de ce fait on est
déjà au coeur du parc et après on peut
aller avec le fauteuil 30 visiter le
musée
on peut aussi revenir là bas faire ce
circuit et après on peut aussi
bénéficier du digipass que l'on peut le
gîte est accessible via internet
accessible on peut manger et bientôt ce
gîte on pourra même coucher parce que
janvier prévu l'aménagement d'une
chambre adaptés aux personnes à mobilité
réduite
voilà tout ça fait que bah c'est plus
plus cet espace aussi bénéfique aussi
bien entendu pour les personnes en
situation de handicap mais aussi pour
les personnes les parents avec des
poussettes et où et les clubs des
personnes d'un personnage est aussi
qu'ils peuvent venir d'en profiter un
peu de la forêt de de la beauté de notre
île aussi parce que là bas
voyez le climat ils tous fait que bah
c'est un moment une journée agréable
magnifique l'accessibilité des sites
naturels est un facteur de progrès
d'autres aménagements doivent suivre
pour rendre les beautés de l'île
accessible à tous nous sommes au
terminus de la route forestière de
bélouve à proximité directe du gîte du
même nom sur un site que le département
a souhaité aménager de façon à le rendre
accessible à tous les publics
alors on va retrouver sur ce pôle nature
différents aménagements accessible un
sentier surélevée qui permet aux
visiteurs de cheminée dans une forêt de
tamarins des eaux
une exposition permanente sur le thème
de l'exploitation de ce même tamarins
donc un boîtier cher aux réunionnais et
le restaurant du gîte et les toilettes
qui sont également accessibles lorsqu'on
parle d'accessibilité ou pense aux
personnes à mobilité réduite
donc les personnes qui sont en fauteuil
on pense aussi aux parents avec des
poussettes et de façon plus générale aux
personnes qui ont du mal à se déplacer
on pense par exemple à certaines de nos
personnes âgées
où certaines personnes souffrantes par
exemple le diabète qui ont un peu de mal
à se déplacer
il y à un haut niveau du gîte la
possibilité de récupérer des audioguides
qui vont permettre au visiteur
malvoyants de se faire guider aussi bien
dans l'exposition que sur le parcours
pour les personnes à mobilité réduite
alors ce projet d'écotourisme il est
emblématique en matière d'accessibilité
et c'est le fruit d'un partenariat
dès le départ on a eu l'opportunité de
travailler avec des représentants du
monde du handicap afin de bien cibler
les besoins et on a eu aussi des
partenaires techniques et financiers on
a travaillé avec l'office national des
forêts qui a réalisé ces aménagements
pour le compte du département
il y a eu le parc national de la réunion
la cirest ainsi que l'union européenne
au travers du fonds feader
au final les réalisations semble
répondre aux attentes exprimées
venez en famille avec vos proches qui
vont pouvoir désormais découvrir avec un
grand confort cet univers luxuriant et
fantasmagorique d'une forêt endémique
est unique au monde
la tamarinaie une exposition pour
connaître l'histoire du téléphérique
forestiers et de l'exploitation de la
forêt est également à découvrir grâce à
l'ensemble de ces aménagements le
département permettent ainsi à tous les
publics de profiter de ce site
remarquable
le conseil départemental de la réunion
vous a présenté lien social
le conseil départemental aux côtés des
réunionnais